CSS allows us to scope styles to particular
conditions. For example, consider the file we have
in front of us. The body rule applies
in all conditions. However, when the device is
in landscape mode, we apply a special rule
to float the menu on the right. Similarly,
if someone decides to print the page, we
resize the text to use a smaller font size.
>> Yeah,
media queries are important for a responsive web design, but
how does this help us optimize a critical rendering path?
>> Great question. First of all, check out
the link in the instructor notes to learn
about media queries. The web fundamentals slide has
a great and detailed explanation of how they
work. And to answer your actual question, let's
say I'm rendering a page that's using this
CSS file. We noted the browser would block
rendering until it parses all of these styles
but intuitively do you think it should block rendering on the print rules?
>> Mm, well, I guess if we're not printing the
page then there's really no reason to block rendering, right?
>> Exactly. This is why it makes sense to sometimes split
the CSS into multiple files. Let's give this a try. Our
first step is to move our print styles into separate file.
Let's call it Style Print CSS. Next, we add an extra
link to our HTML mark up. And here's the important part, by default the browser
assumes that each specified style sheet is
render blocking. However, we can also tell the
browser when the style sheet should be
applied by adding a media attribute with the
media query. In this case, sense style-print.css
is only used for print, we add media-print.
>> Oh, so now when the browser sees a style sheet it knows that it only
needs to apply it for printing and hence it doesn't need to block rendering when
we're loading on the phone. You got it.
The browser still downloads both style sheets, but
it wouldn't block rendering on style-print.css. And
in this particular case it just means that
the browser has to download less data for
style.css which would help with the download speed.
>> That makes sense. But this is a pretty trivial example. Let's say
I've got a much more complicated set of styles with multiple break points.
Would this technique help here as well?
>> Absolutely, you can specify any media query on
the link attribute, and the browser will do the right
thing. Once again, check out the article in the
instructor notes for directions on how to use media queries.
>> Okay, now the page feed recommendations about reducing the
number of critical CSS elements makes a lot more sense.
>> Glad to hear. let's do a quick quiz to test your understanding.